normal understanding is that you trust  the theory the only reason to trust a  theory is that the theory has been  confirmed empirically which means that  the theory makes predictions and those  predictions are then then turn out to be  in agreement with empirical data this  means that any theory that hasn't found  empirical confirmation must be  considered a pure speculation  and this seems to be not quite right  there are theories that haven't found  empirical confirmation but they which  are trusted quite a lot by physicists  for example string theory string theory  hasn't found any empirical confirmation  but many string theorists think they  have very good reasons for trusting the  theory and I want to to understand this  based on the concept of what I call  non-empirical confirmation the idea is  that there are observations about the  context of scientific inquiry about  about the development of a theory and so  on and those observation can generate  trust in the theory